il prend feu rapidement imbibé d'alcool
le drapeau aux serpents et brûlé par les
militants posé sur la statue de
joséphine de beauharnais
nous sommes le 23 août choisi par
l'unesco pour se souvenir de la traite
les militant du mir ont décidé de
manifester sur la savane dans leur
collimateur les symboles de l' esclavage
qui perdure ici notamment sur cette
place centrale de fort de france en
place coupez coupez la haye pour le jour
à interroger les passants
joséphine de beauharnais accusés d'avoir
encouragé le rétablissement de
l'esclavagé de l'un des noms bucs le
conquérant qui s'est emparée de la
martinique de symboles dont ils ne
veulent plus quant au drapeau il est
contesté depuis déjà une dizaine
d'années c'est un pavillon à bulles qui
était sur les pavillons des grilles et
de saint cyr qui a la simple ici en
martinique qui étaient des colonies
françaises à l'époque
et ben c'est pas villon pour nous fait
l'apologie de crimes contre l'humanité
et ils assimilable à la ramée et il est
inadmissible qu'un nous qu'il soit soit
des bâtiments publics aux états unis en
ce moment les statuts d'esclavagistes
sont purement et simplement des
boulonnais par la foule
c'est peut-être ce que craignaient les
policiers venus nombreux
mais resté finalement en observation la
manifestation fait réagir aux provoque
la discussion dépasse en connaissant
l'histoire de joséphine et de napoléon
quelque part ce n'est pas très glorieux
vous
comme un ticket et vous allez en france
et vous avez monsieur déjà mais je vis
en france
jamais un dieu mais pour eux ils sont
toujours dans l'histoire passée où il
voudrait se libérer du joug de la france
d'alors du colonialisme
ce n'est pas la première fois que des
militants manifestent contre les statuts
joséphine en particulier porte les
traces de plusieurs actions sa tête
notamment a été enlevé il ya 25 ans